in the wolf of Wall Street Jordan
Belfort lives nothing short of an
extravagant lifestyle with the 12
billion dollar yacht three million our
house
helicopter supercars and hundreds of
questionable parties in the last video
we covered how exactly Jordan was able
to make this money without getting
caught in this video we will be covering
how he was able to spend it without
being caught as a film just slightly
touches on the subject so how did Jordan
spend his fortune
[Music]
well starting off Jorn used two methods
to launder the money that he had been
stealing which were rat holes and
offshore accounts he used rat holes to
live and offshore accounts to save and
maintain his wealth rat holes are simply
all of Jordans friends who were involved
in a money laundering process rat holes
are simply people under which money can
be hidden these people are often paid
commissions of about 10 percent to just
user identities in various frauds
throughout Jorns pump and dump scheme he
would never hold investment in the
company he was pumping up north avoid
suspicion he would always get these rat
holes to invest like companies whose
values he was inflating as a result
Jordan was already in their clear for
when the FBI or SEC would investigate
his name as he was not directly linked
to the scheme so all jor needed to do in
order to make this money usable was to
figure out a way to get money from these
rat holes to his own name without
raising suspicion of involvement and
this was actually really simple as all
of his rat holes were already fraudsters
themselves working for an Oakland they
had legitimate partial ownership of
Stratton Oakmont in other words they
were legitimate investors in the company
from day one so it wasn't out of the
ordinary for these Rajas to invest money
into the company they were long-term
investors and as long as their
investments were consistently spread out
and not surprisingly large the FBI
couldn't link these investments to a
potential pump and dump scheme but of
course they had to first trick the FBI
that that form stage backhauls had were
from a legitimate sources and this too
was quite easy as all of their activity
was actually won her percent legal these
rock holes had simply invested in penny
stocks and sold them when their prices
increased the only thing they had to be
wary of was being charged for insider
trading or the trading of stocks using
confidential information the thing is
it's not that hard to get away with
insider trading
legally even today as long as one
adheres to SEC guidelines one of these
guidelines
is that insiders simply have to stick to
trading based only on information that's
available to the public for at least two
full business days this information
could be a wide range of things from
annual reports to press releases and
marketing materials here's the idea
behind the role when a company like
Apple or Microsoft releases annual
reports investors will be exposed to
numbers and have the opportunity base or
trading decisions on them as a result if
insiders were forced to wait two days
before selling or buying any shares this
would theoretically prevent them from
being able to sell before a stock
plummet or buy before a stock surge
given insider knowledge but the thing is
how many investors are actually paying
attention to any reports of a penny
stock company a penny stock company
could release her annual reports months
before Rajas buy into the company and
this wouldn't affect the press the penny
stock in any way
this information was technically
available to the public for well over
two days and raffles can simply say they
base our investments on these useless
annual reports and that completes the
entire scheme rat-holes invest in penny
stocks without using inside information
and then they sell their shares when
they see the price is just brandonna
skyrocketing after this they invest most
of these profits into Stratton Oakmont
because their investors in that company
as well finally Jordan can take these
funds as a salary bonus throw parties or
really whatever he wants as you can see
these circuits of money-laundering
are quite easy to spot and this is why
the FBI and SEC were investigating
Stratton Oakmont from the very beginning
however is near impossible to prove
money laundering without one of the
links in this chain confessing as
Stratton eyes were very well compensated
none of them even thought about
confessing in interest of
self-preservation on paper all of your
activities are legal and as long as they
stick to the proscribed guidelines and
don't launder too much money at any
given time they can indefinitely get
away with it this is how Jordan was able
to get away with spending millions to
this lavish life but this is not the
only money-laundering that he was
involved in when the SEC was closing in
on cracking his pump and dump scheme
John would offer much of his wealth to
Swiss banks and this is what would
eventually lead to his money-laundering
charges up until 1999 Swiss banks for
the perfect place to launder money
Switzerland did not advocate for my
lagering whatsoever at any time but
they're friendly banking policies were
favorable for money laundering
they have cracked down heavily on
foreign money laundering since 1999
though but given the situation before
1999 it really was as simple as opening
a Swiss bank account under his wife's
and name and then basically shipping
suitcases filled money the aunt simply
needed to spend at least $10,000 a month
in order to make the count team active
and this would also serve as her
commission till the very end the Swiss
bank would not hand over the account
details on the basis of a
money-laundering investigation to the
FBI so how did the FBI finally get
through with Joran seaming on penetrable
safety net and convict him for both
securities fraud and money laundering if
you would like to know that make sure
drop a like and subscribe to see that
question logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one